- [Voiceover] Let's think a
little bit how energy flows,
and how matter is
recycled in an ecosystem.
And so the whole time that
we go through this video,
think about these two ideas.
And even after watching this video,
look at ecosystems around yourself,
even ones that you're a part of
and think about how energy
flows and how matter's recycled.
Let's first think about energy.
The energy for most ecosystems
originally comes from the Sun.
There are other sources of energy,
you could think about even moonlight,
but that essentially comes from the Sun.
But there's also geothermal energy,
but the Sun is a source of
most energy for most ecosystems
we could think of.
And how does the ecosystem
make use of that energy?
How does it get into,
how does it that get
stored within the ecosystem
especially as biomass?
Well, it starts with primary producers
which are usually going to be plants.
They can also be bacteria that
are able to photosynthesize,
or that are able to take that
energy and create biomolecules
that store energy from it.
And so these are primary producers,
these plants in this diagram.
Sometimes you'll see them
referred to as autotrophs.
They are getting their
own food from the Sun,
from this energy.
And once again, how is that energy stored?
Well, it's stored in these
biological molecules.
If you were to zoom in into
the molecules in this plant,
and this is a huge oversimplification,
you'll see all these bonds
between these carbons.
And to make those bonds requires energy
and if you were to break those bonds
it could release energy.
And you might say, well,
where did all these carbons
come from that are in this tree?
Well, the carbon is coming from the air.
Our air has carbon dioxide in it.
It has carbon dioxide,
so those are the carbons,
maybe let me draw some oxygens.
So two oxygens for every carbon.
And the whole process of photosynthesis
is all about fixing that carbon.
Let me write that word down.
We are fixing that carbon
from a gaseous form when
it's part of carbon dioxide,
into the structure of the plant,
into the biological
molecules of the plant.
So it's storing that energy.
Now it's not a perfectly
efficient process.
Not all of the energy from the Sun
is going to be able to be stored.
Some of it is being reflected.
Even the plant itself as it lives,
as it reproduces, as its cells divide,
some of that energy is used.
And eventually, that
energy is released as heat.
And you're gonna see this trend a lot
in thermodynamic systems,
that you're going from one energy,
you're using energy to do some work,
but in the process, you are
going to be producing heat.
But this is just the
beginning of our energy flow.
Now we could think about
how that energy now flows
to the other actors in the ecosystem.
So the next phase, and this
is a very simplified diagram
or ecosystem that we're thinking about.
Most ecosystems are far,
far, far more complex.
Let's think about the characters
that would eat the plants,
the characters that would
eat the primary producers,
and we call the folks that
we call them primary consumers.
So this bunny, or this
squirrel right over here,
they are primary consumers.
They consume the primary producers.
And why do they consume them?
Why does a bunny eat the grass?
Well, because it gets
energy from those bonds
in the biological molecules,
from those carbon bonds,
and other bonds.
And it's able to use that
energy to grow itself,
to reproduce, to live, to run around,
and it also stores some of
that energy in its own biomass.
And once again, this process
is not very efficient.
Going from one layer of trophic
to another layer of trophic,
you only have about 10%,
10% of the energy gets transferred
or gets stored in the next layer.
Why only 10%?
Well, because not all
of the plants get eaten.
The whole process of eating
plants, digesting plants,
some of the energy gets pooped out,
gets pooped out
because the primary consumer
here, or the consumer
isn't able to get all of it out
of the actual biological molecules.
And so overall, it's
an inefficient process.
Now, we're not done yet.
We still have energy stored
in the biological molecules
of this primary consumer that someone
might be interested in.
And we know that in many ecosystems
there are things that like to
eat rabbits or even squirrels.
And in this drawing it will be this fox.
And this fox because it
eats primary consumers,
we would call it a secondary consumer.
The secondary consumer.
And you could keep going on with this
if there were some character out here.
Let's say there's some guy
who likes to eat foxes.
That's a knife in his hand that he uses
to go after the foxes with.
Well, so the fox could go to him,
and once again, why is he eating foxes?
Well, he wants that energy in that fox,
and actually it's not
just about molecules.
We'll talk about matter in a second.
He wants the energy and
the matter from the fox
to grow and live himself.
And so this character would
be called a tertiary consumer.
Tertiary consumer.
And if there's no one
who wants to eat him,
well then he would be
considered an apex consumer,
or an apex predator.
And these characters
that eat other animals,
we've talked about it before,
they're called carnivores.
But let me just say, he's the apex.
And apex, we're really thinking
about the top of the food chain.
That's why they're called,
that would be called an apex
consumer, or an apex predator.
But we're not done yet
because at some point
all of these characters,
whether we're talking
about the trees, the bunnies, the fox,
this character who likes to eat foxes,
they're going to die.
And that energy just doesn't disappear.
In general, you're going to see,
energy is conserved and it
flows from one place to another.
That energy is then going to
be used by these characters
right over here, which
we call decomposers.
They can take all that leftover
energy and that dead carcass
or even in the poop, and
they can make use of it,
once again, for them to
live, for them to reproduce.
And then by breaking that down,
they can release a lot of those nutrients
and the matter that's used.
And once again, the matter's recycled,
once again, to be used by the plants.
So it creates this really nice cycle.
And the important thing to realize is
that it comes in as light
that energy gets transferred
as we go through the
different layers of trophic.
And it's not a completely
efficient process,
and a lot of that energy,
especially as these organisms
live, and reproduce,
and run around gets released as heat.
Now we've focused a lot on the energy,
let's think a little about the matter.
I've already touched on it,
but the matter is recycled.
There isn't, at least the
way that we've set this up,
there isn't new matter that is entering
or leaving these ecosystems
or being magically created
or magically destroyed.
As I mentioned, when you look at a leaf
on a plant growing, or a tree growing,
or a leave of grass growing,
that matter isn't just
coming out of nowhere,
it's coming out of,
it's just a different form,
or maybe the best way to put it,
that matter was always there
in the form of carbon dioxide.
The plant is just using
that energy from the Sun
to fix that carbon from a
gas form into a solid form.
And it's able to use
that energy to form bonds
between the carbons in
these biological molecules
that actually store energy.
And the plant can use that energy to grow
and as we've talked about,
things that eat the plants,
or things that eat the
things that eat the plants
can use that energy.
And as we talked before,
the carbon dioxide
comes in these plants.
And maybe this arrow might
be a little bit misleading,
so let me erase that for now.
But we release oxygen, O2.
That oxygen, and we've seen that as part
of the photosynthesis process,
that oxygen is used by
the animals to metabolize
these biological molecules.
We studied that in biology in respiration.
And the matter itself, as we say,
we have this carbon right over here.
When it gets eaten, well
then that becomes part
of the bio molecules inside of this bunny,
and when the bunny uses any
of these biological molecules
as a source of energy so it's
able to break those bonds
through respiration.
Well, then that carbon
gets released in the form
of carbon dioxide, so
maybe this is a better way.
Oh, actually it was already
drawn right over here.
And so the important thing
to realize is that energy
is flowing, light from the
Sun comes in, it's slow,
you know all this action goes on,
and then it gets released as heat
on almost every step,
but the matter itself,
it's always been there.
All of the atoms in our body, on Earth,
it's just constantly being recycled.
It's actually was
generated inside of stars
many, many billions of years ago,
and we just keep reusing it
over, and over, and over again.
It gets recycled from one form to another,
even after all of these actors die,
the decomposers break them down
into simple inorganic molecules.
As we talked about before,
that can then be used as
the plants in conjunction
with the carbon from the air
and the light from the Sun
and water that it gets through its roots
to start that process
all over, all over again.